when it comes to investing nobody holds
a candle to Jim Simons not Warren
Buffett not Steven Cohen not George sorz
Simon Company Renaissance Technologies
has a signature hedge fund called
Medallion that has generated average
annual returns of
66% for 30 years to put this another way
renowned Economist Bradford Cornell
points out that if you had invested $100
in Medallion in 1988 30 years later that
would have turned into
398.62
what's even more remarkable is that
Simons hired people who didn't know a
thing about investing is it true that
you never hired people from the
investment industry
never he hired mathematicians and
scientists just like himself while
traditional investors rely on intuition
to make trades chatting with Executives
analyzing earnings reports cleaning
insights from articles and considering
geopolitical events Simons walked a
different path as a trained
mathematician he believed mark markets
moved in logical ways so we took a
scientific approach to investing
harnessing the power of vast data sets
computer models and algorithms to make
decisions inspiring a revolution that
has swept Wall Street this is the story
of how a mathematician became the
greatest traitor who ever lived Jim
Simons is always Restless building a
stored career as a brilliant
mathematician wasn't enough neither was
teaching at MIT in Harvard neither was
working as a cold war codebreaker he
left Harvard to join an elite research
organization that helped America's most
secretive intelligence agency the NSA
decode Soviet messages during the Cold
War but the work didn't satisfy him as
his first wife Barbara recalled in
Gregory zucker's book The Man Who solved
the market Jim understood at an early
age that money is power growing up an
only child in Brookline Massachusetts
near Boston his family doctor encouraged
him to consider a career in medicine
remarking you're a bright Jewish boy you
should be a doctor but when Simon shared
his passion for mathematics the doctor
replied look you can't make any money
doing that stuff Simons always wanted to
be rich when he was fired from his
codebreaking job for protesting the
Vietnam War he wanted to join an
investment Bank he had three young
children to support including a son who
was born with a rare hereditary
condition that affected the development
of his skin hair sweat glands and teeth
but he opted to stay in Academia for the
time being he was offered a job to head
the math department at Stony Brook
University on Long Island while it
wasn't as renowned then here he was at
the age of 30 with the opportunity to
shape his own mathematics Department
while at Stonybrook he developed a
mathematical theory that is foundational
to the work of Microsoft and other
companies to create special quantum
computers designed to tackle challenges
beyond the reach of our current systems
including in AI as his professional life
took off his personal life suffered he
and Barbara were young when they got
married he was 21 she was 18 they
divorced and she headed west to complete
her PhD in computer science at UC
Berkeley a few years later a lingering
urge nudg Simons to leave Academia and
Venture into the world of Finance by
starting his own investment firm his
father thought he was making a huge
mistake by leaving a tenur position
mathematicians were shocked and felt he
was wasting his talent but Simons was
always unconventional evidenced by small
gestures like not wearing socks because
they took too much time to put on at the
age of 40 he left his position at
Stonybrook to open up a small office in
a strip mall across from a train station
near the university and so began
Renaissance Technologies in 1978 back
then it was called monometric a play on
money and econometrics the use of
statistics and math to study economic
data just as he once unscrambled enemy
code he aimed to decode hidden patterns
in the market Simon remarked to
Zuckerman in his book there's a pattern
here there has to be a pattern he didn't
care why the patterns exist Ed just that
they did Renaissance began by trading
currencies Commodities in bonds but
avoided stocks due to their complexity
there are so many of them and each stock
is influenced by the unique
circumstances of its company Simons
envisioned a trading system fully Guided
by algorithms with no human input let's
say you want to know what the weather
will be like tomorrow you feed a
computer the information you have on
past rainfalls temperatures and humidity
levels the computer model processes the
information to predict tomorrow's
conditions an algorithm then advises you
on whether to carry an umbrella
translated to the realm of quantitative
Finance the weather data becomes
financial data such as stock prices and
trading volumes the weather forecast
becomes a market forecast and the advice
on what to wear translates to a trading
decision on the other hand a traditional
investor might try to predict the
weather or the market based on subtle
clues in their environment like how much
pain they're in because of their
arthritis as much as Simon dreamt of
this kind of trading system computers in
the'80s were just not sophisticated
enough to handle a fully automated
system so at the start Renaissance
relied on math models and human
intuition to trade which proved
problematic his code-breaking colleague
Leonard Bal who now worked at
Renaissance liked to buy low but often
clung to positions too long like in 1984
when he heavily invested in US bonds but
as the Reagan Administration began
issuing so many bonds prices plummeted
Simons recognized the limits of human
judgment and brought in James ax a
friend from his PhD days at UC Berkeley
whom he recruited to Sony Brook to build
more sophisticated math models for
trading the team collected data from as
far back as the 1800s feeding them into
computers to uncover overlooked patterns
Simons told a colleague if we have
enough data I know we can make
predictions Simons and axe launched a
new hedge fund Medallion in honor of the
prestigious math Awards they'd received
Medallion would eventually become the
most successful Hedge fund of all time
but at first it struggled to make a
profit it didn't help that axe isolated
himself in his Seaside estate in Malibu
his preference for the West Coast led
him to spearhead his new company axcom a
separate entity yet closely connected to
Renaissance the Turning Point came when
elwin burle Camp who had worked to crack
codes with Simons bought up ax as part
of the business he rebuilt the system to
focus on short-term trades which Axe had
resisted due to concerns over commission
fees Bur figured if you trade a lot you
only need to be right 51% of the time
many investors prefer long-term trades a
sentiment Zuckerman describes in his
book this way like fishermen ignoring
the Guppies in their Nets hoping for a
bigger catch unlike these investors
Medallion honed in on these Guppies
seeking to capitalize on subtle
inefficiencies that others overlooked
don't give up
easily stick with
it stick with it not for forever but
really give it a chance to get where
you're going and the uh final principle
is hope for good
luck after a decade of adjusting their
algorithms aided by improved computer
processing power Renaissance turned the
corner in 1990 The Medallion fund posted
gains after fees of
58% but Simons believed they could do
even better he wanted 80% returns bur
Camp thought he was crazy and it all
became too much for him he returned to
teaching at UC Berkeley Simons bought
burle Camp's share of the company and
axcom which had been a separate entity
disbanded going forward it was just
Renaissance Technologies Simons beefed
up the team some more Henry laugher a
mathematician from Stony Brooke divided
the trading day into 5minute intervals
instead of hourly allowing Renaissance
to quickly detect and act on even
shorter term price changes their models
were so successful at making trades that
they trusted their computers to make
decisions that didn't even make sense to
them there was however one issue
Renaissance was still very small it only
managed 45 million after 10 years in the
business a quarter of the assets of
rival firm de Shaw David Shaw was also
using computer models to trade and he
was trading stocks unlike Renaissance
Simons knew if he truly wanted to leave
a legacy he had to start trading stocks
he Consolidated all operations in Long
Island and was about to embark on A New
Path when tragedy
struck Simon's son Paul who had battled
a birth disorder was cycling in
Stonybrook when he was struck by a car
and killed the elderly driver was so
traumatized by what happened that she
died of a heart attack a few days later
the grief of losing a child caused
Simons to throw himself into his work in
order to master the art of trading
stocks he needed more help Simons
recruited Robert Mercer and Peter Brown
renowned for their groundbreaking work
in transcribing speech into text at IBM
they saw language as a probabilistic
game where some words likely follow
others for instance after chocolate milk
is more probable than cheese similarly
Simons wanted to design a system that
could predict Financial market trends
with their coding chops Brad and Mercer
crafted a single automated stock trading
system introduced in 1995 complete with
half a million lines of code compared to
tens of thousands in the old system
after Mercer and brown mastered stocks
The Medallion fund took off in 2000 it
achieved a return after fees of
98.5% even amidst the Doom bubble
showcasing renaissance's prowess in
capitalizing on
inefficiencies Simons rewarded his staff
with exotic vacations and bonuses these
computer science nerds who were in it
for the challenge not the money couldn't
help but reap the financial Rewards
staff could personally invest in
Medallion in fact as Medallion grew it
closed its stores to outside investors
in 2003 and is only available to
employees the fund is capped at $10
billion they bought so many mansions in
one neighborhood that had earned the
nickname Renaissance Riviera how exactly
Renaissance has managed to achieve these
stunning results is a secret employees
are bound by non-disclosure agreements
ensuring they remain silent about the
coding and algorithm Renaissance uses
many firms on Wall Street are trying to
crack the Renaissance code JP Morgan
Chase makes it mandatory for new
investment bankers and managers to learn
coding with advancements in technology
and AI more data sets can be collected
and analyzed even scrutinizing the tone
of voice Executives use on conference
calls monitoring which aisle Shoppers
spend most of their time in grocery
stores or analyzing the social media
posts to gauge sentiment by the way
let's connect on X I'm at news Medallion
is the most successful hedge fund of all
time the returns are so high that it
charges a performance fee of
44% Simons had achieved everything he
wanted to achieve in the world of
investing he thought about retiring but
then tragedy struck
again his son Nicholas wanted to become
a doctor and open up a medical clinic in
Nepal to help its poorest people a week
before he was scheduled to come home he
drowned while free diving in Bali Simons
had to bury a second child for a man who
believed so strongly in science and
logic this unbearable loss was a
reminder of the inherent
unpredictability of life he threw
himself into his work once again to
distract him from his grief Simons
launched a larger fund the Renaissance
institutional equities fund which is
available to outside investors Reef
whether the storm of the 2007 subprime
mortgage crisis triggered by high-risk
loans given to Americans with
questionable Credit in an unusual move
owing to extraordinary circumstances
Simons felt the need for human
intervention guiding his team to reduce
Equity positions in build cash reserves
ultimately Renaissance rebounded and
during the turmoil of 2008 Medallion
boasted 82% in profits highlighting the
sophistication and adaptability of their
trading systems having achieved all that
he wanted in the world of investing
Simon stepped down as CEO of Renaissance
technology IES in 2009 handing over the
Reigns to Brown and Mercer throughout
his career Simons maintained a low
public profile compared to some of his
peers yet the spotlight couldn't help
but shine on Renaissance because of its
new co-ceo Robert Mercer Mercer
distrusted the government disapproved of
the clintons and questioned whether
humans are the primary cause of climate
change he emerged as one of Trump's
biggest Financial backers in 2016 as he
felt only an outsider could win the
election the mer family also acquired a
significant stake in the conservative
Outlet Breitbart News Mercer's daughter
Rebecca recommended the head of
Breitbart Steve Bannon run Trump's
campaign while Kelly and Conway became a
familiar face on TV together Bannon and
Conway helped Propel Trump to the White
House on the other hand Simons was a
significant supporter of Hillary
Clinton's campaign despite their
different political leanings Simons felt
Mercer shouldn't be fired for his
political actions but then it started to
affect business Renaissance programmer
David meerman was horrified by the
election of trump and expressed concerns
about Mercer's involvement to Zuckerman
for the Wall Street Journal investors
shared similar concerns when the
Baltimore City Fire and Police employees
retirement system pulled 32 million from
Renaissance The Firm feared a mass
Exodus Simon suggested Mercer stepped
down according to Zuckerman Mercer quote
looked sad and hurt in November 2017
Mercer resigned as co-ceo at Renaissance
Technologies and sold his stake in
Breitbart News to his daughters as for
Simons with a personal net worth of 27
billion he can afford to indulge in
luxuries like a $100 million
superat yet his wealth doesn't just fund
lavish Pursuits he's donated 500 million
to Stony Brook University established a
nonprofit that provides exceptional Math
teachers with additional support and
started a charitable Foundation that
among other Pursuits is dedicated to
autism research a cause close to his
heart as his daughter Audrey with his
second wife is autistic the Simons
Foundation is also heavily focused on
discovering the origins of the universe
its Observatory under construction in
sh's atakama desert will search for
gravitational waves from The Big Bang
hoping to unravel the mysteries of the
universe's first moments perhaps history
will not remember Simon solely for being
a master of markets but as the master of
the
universe Jim Simons would never have
become the greatest traitor of all time
had it not been for his background in
mathematics strengthening your math
skills is invaluable regardless of your
profession and there's a free way to
boost your skills I highly recommend
brillian a website and app where you can
learn math data science and computer
science interactively I personally take
a few minutes out of my day to go
through Brilliance logic puzzles to
improve my analytical thinking you can
start at your own Comfort level and then
progress to more advanced lessons and if
you get stuck you can view the
explanation to discover the correct
approach you can try out brilliant for
free for 30 days using my link in the
description brilliant.org
newthink if you're one of the first 200
people to sign up via my link you'll get
20% off your premium subscription
unlocking all of brilliant's courses
thanks for watching for news think I'm
Cindy pal